ladies and gentlemen my name is Ryan the
right and my name is Jerry the Jerry
welcome to reasons to see where we give
you reasons to see and not to see
prisoners so let's break out of this
cage recent a seat number one Hugh
Jackman when he first starts yelling all
you started thinking of his Wolverine
yeah Hugh Jackman's rockin it this year
man The Wolverine was great he was
awesome in that and now he's back in
this and most people are saying like
this is his best performance it's
personally got my favorite performance
of your Jackman that I can totally see
why it's like considered his best by a
lot of people he's very believable as as
this you know sort of survivalist guy
who's flying off the handle even just
those quiet moments where he's like
stuttering and stuff and in the latter
moments when he's screaming at everybody
he really doesn't come across real and
it's it's great it's a [ __ ] heart roll
because it's a totally complex guy and
it's one of the most complex characters
I've seen all year it's such a roll of
what if I was in this position would you
go to this these links you know the
trailer when I first saw the trailer I
thought the trailer like ruined the
whole movie yeah but then you watch this
movie and you're like it doesn't really
ruin much actually yeah it only feeds
you one small part of the plot that only
feeds like the first third of the movie
so in the trailer you see that like Hugh
Jackman takes Paul Dano the guy who's
accused of possibly kidnapping his
daughter and he pretty much decides I'm
gonna torture this guy and keep him
prisoner until one of the pretty ladies
one of the prisoners you know it's
really but would you go this far would
you actually do all those things and
Hugh Jackman is such a good job in it
because he manages to make this guy so
understanding at the same time and you
feel for him you don't look at him as
the bad guy but he's doing bad guy
things oh man he's just fantastic in the
role he's absolutely wonderful yeah well
it's got that complexity and it's also
dynamic because
in the film you do get to see them you
know they go to a dinner party with
Terrence Howard and his wife and you get
to see this guy you know laughing and
having a good evening and then when
everything goes wrong you get to see how
morally questionable and scary this guy
can get it's in such a way that feels
real just because of how they set up
that character it is very real like cuz
one thing I was thinking was this could
have been a role that could have easily
been OneNote you know just some guy
who's got like I gotta get my you know
my vengeance I gotta find my would give
me back my family it's never been the
perfect Harrison Ford performance
Harrison Ford's voice sounds like a like
a grumpy bowl of oatmeal to me yeah the
older he gets the more like weird yeah
you're our only hope and think in this
movie it definitely gets the dark roll
down he's good he's good show you know
it's totally different from overing
that's a lot of confusion yeah nothing
like whoa boy weird facial hair and he's
got a temper problem is this like I feel
like the opposite of Wolverine because
all the fit all the beers right here not
overrated it's all here so if you
combine these two roles he would have a
full beard recency number two Jake
Gyllenhaal Jake Gyllenhaal is the [ __ ]
he in this movie he is probably I mean
there was a lot of stuff I like about
this movie but he is my favorite thing
in this movie yeah he's probably my
favorite character to actually like I
think the Academy Award performance is
probably gonna go to Hugh Jackman I
think people are gonna really overlook
Jake Gyllenhaal's performance in this
film because it's subtle but it's it's
[ __ ] deep as ever at the same time
the plays detective Loki can't wait for
all those [ __ ] Thor jokes yeah but in
prisoners too you know it's gonna be the
Thor kidnapped about the bugler yeah
Jake Gyllenhaal plays this like cop who
you don't really know too much about his
personal life but you can feel the whole
backstory you get hints of him you know
a foster home cut the deals going on and
stuff he's just cool he's [ __ ] cool in
this film he is oh and also he is so
real like yes like the way he reacts to
everything I'm like damn why
it doesn't feel like he's acting at all
it's like you know he still looks like
Jake Gyllenhaal but I totally lost him
in the role of you know detective Loki
it's all in the little things it's like
a lot of the time you know people aren't
behaving in a way that's helping him
solve the case and it's like you know
Hugh Jackman's walking over the car just
thinking it's sort of leaned back at the
scene be like like dammit
yeah and there's like those little
things that made it so great and he's
also you know a very different dynamic
from much of the rest of the cast which
makes him so interesting because he is
more sort of mellow in intensity you
know and him and Hugh Jackman have such
great rhythm playing off of each other
the back and forth between them so good
because Hugh Jackman is always giving
Jake Gyllenhaal [ __ ] like weren't you
point of my daughter yeah exactly
I'm trying man you've been a few days
give me a break exactly yeah you kind of
go back and forth between their sides
but it is like I can totally see how
difficult it is to deal with this guy
who just won't take any answer other
than the one that he wants and you watch
Jake Gyllenhaal sort of struggle with
that and also you know struggle with the
case itself and he's great yeah you see
how like you know you got back that
copper allworthy the case is taking a a
toll on his emotions and stuff but it's
done in such an authentic way where
you're not thinking of other like cop
performances you know you're so
engrossed in this role here it's the
first Jake Gyllenhaal performance I've
seen where I'm just you know really
invested in the character I'm not aware
that's jake gyllanhall because normally
Jake Gyllenhaal's in movies where he's
outside by somebody else yeah it's like
I never and this isn't anything against
it but I never thought I would be like
Jake Gyllenhaal like I loved his
performance and this movie I'm like I
love his Brianna's in this movie she's
good and he's pairing up with the
director again for the very next film I
hope so and he's playing to people in
that movie yeah so I'm excited for that
reason to see number three Paul Dano
Paul Dano clean Yeti and another so
creepy good Oh nobody's like in real
life I was a cool dude
because in every performance I see him
and he's like some introverted awkward
you know guy who doesn't really like to
express himself too much I imagine in
real life he is calm but but intense
I hear he's in a band or something is he
really yeah
check me as a kind of guy being a man
does he play the bass he looks like a
bass but it looks like you play to make
[ __ ] be a bass player yeah I think
Christman's plus is a drummer no way
yeah he's a drummer in a band yeah [ __ ]
yeah they called the young grab the
aliens oh they must be super bad bass
yeah both dads in this film and he's uh
he's creepy as always and he's really
good at pointing these roles he's
someone who's is always believable as
these like socially awkward types of
outcasts I really enjoyed him in it even
though it was like it's Paulin and I'm
playing Paul Dano again you know it's
still fantastic only few people can pull
off such a weird [ __ ] role and make
it this authentic at the same time so
kudos to him I could see why they turn
to him for roles like this because how
many people can do it oh yeah I mean I
love Paul Dano he's one of those sort of
character actor guys who whatever I hear
he's in something I'm always like I want
to check that out now and he's great in
this movie he's very you know strange
you know like you said very awkward
character and he's so good at playing
that and he does a good job of making
you wonder like is this guy guilty or is
he not guilty that's just pre because
you constantly go back and forth be
going going he's in this in to maybe he
is responsible yeah no no no no no dude
Hugh Jackman kill him you know by an
executive on stantly go back and forth
of this guy he's probably got the
hardest role in it because he has to do
so much expression without dialogue I
think it's gonna be another performance
that's overlooked this movie overall
just has wonderful acting in it leave it
Terrence Howard's on on the list but
even he does a really good job in this
movie too
Viola Davis is great you know and Maria
Bello Melissa Leo is awesome like you
know the whole cast is great in this
movie any you know flaw of the movie has
the acting is certainly for the most
part not one of those flows yeah
definitely reason to see number four the
writing Aaron Guzikowski okay guy wrote
contraband no wait you're a contract and
he wrote this movie yeah it's a big step
the writing in this absolutely stellar I
really dug this film a lot this the way
the whole movie unfolds it's like a
mystery thriller at the same time it's a
it's a very emotional drama
you get like all these different
elements in it and it's executed so
wonderfully well where it's like you're
yeah you're on the journey it's always
interesting and it's always thrilling
and at a time this is just so goddamn
dark and gritty it is a door yeah it's
really it really is a dark pit damn is
it good like what left this script the
actors going to have them able to shine
so [ __ ] well yeah I mean it's it's a
really interesting mystery then they've
got setup and also it's you know I'm
sure if you've ever read a writing book
or heard somebody talk about writing
it's something I noticed is that he
really went out of his way to make sure
that every character has a very
different voice every character has a
unique sort of aura in a vibe you know
it's like Paul Dano hardly speaks at all
Jake Gyllenhaal's very reserved and very
sort of like I said mellow intense so
the way he talks is specific and then
you have hugh jackman who's kind of
blowing up all the time so it's like
everyone is written very distinctly and
there's Maria Bello it was like just so
into like the stage of like great fun
right now you know like she's constantly
hovering back between like shocking and
blame all the time exactly it's just
fantastic they the questions of morality
and vision on the themes that are
portrayed here all of it it's just I
don't want to spoil it if they just just
know that they got a lot of things that
artistically done here but they're all
done it is such an entertaining fashion
the mystery is is is the centerpiece I
guess you would say but there is a lot
of that on the periphery just like how
this situation would affect the people
involved and that's the stuff that those
sort of colors in the lines it makes it
really that much more interesting when
you break this phone down especially
when you watch the trailer it's very
easy to make a story like this be like
such a Hollywood screenplay action dad
when you watch the trailer you think
like that part where he kidnaps Paul dad
is gonna happen like towards the finale
of the film or something yeah but then
you you watch this phone in the way it
all plays out it's smart there's twists
there's turns and I love the reveals
that happen and stuff it's it's it's
it's a great ride at the same time it's
very emotional
yeah and very dark yep it's a dark
emotional ride like like Riddler's
revenge reason to see number 5 the
directing and cinematography right off
the bat first thing I know this
cinematography beautiful seriously Roger
Deakins never does wrong you know like
he did Skyfall that's the last movie I
remember him doing then a shitload of
stuff Shawshank Redemption yeah the
guy's been around he's one of the top
cinematographers working today no
question about it you know there's like
a haunting Menace behind the
cinematography it's it's interesting
because it takes place in like kind of
like a small town in a way it's like
simple yet it's beautiful at the same
time just to what the atmosphere and how
they capture it all oh yeah lots of
lines get slow push in yeah they really
take time to just establish the error in
you know all these places and make it
sort of feel kind of tight and paranoid
it's sort of look like dry but I didn't
feel anything like driving it smooth
this film like the director um Dennis
Veon view or villain view I don't know
something ability or something
Dennis will call him he his direction on
this was perfect like the tone
established was excellent yeah I don't
think a crappy director could have made
it it's got so many different genres at
play here and he managed to pull off
such a perfect execution he obviously
knows his characters obviously knows how
to work well with his actors Deanna and
he's top of that knows how to perk with
a cinematographer to get some gorgeous
cinematography going on you know this is
a two and a half hour film it's not one
of those films that is completely plot
driven like it so every scene is all new
plot developments like there is a lot of
cutting back and forth between character
moments and stuff and and I never got
bored during this you know I was never
like okay I'm tired of this it's like
everything was engrossing and it's that
combination of the direction and the
cinematography and the acted just
everything working together you know
really makes that tight and really makes
it so that two and a half hours feel
like to happen will say yeah for a two
and a half hour film it it went by like
it was it was a really immersive
experience I think I think I caught
myself in the middle going I am NOT
noticing that this is two and a half
it has all the elements you need for a
great movie at the same time that
doesn't sacrifice entertainment value
there are some very tense you know
moments there's a scene where Jake
Gyllenhaal is racing to a hospital for
whatever reason and it is it is intense
oh yeah oh that's a great scene there's
a lot of really intense scenes you know
a lot of people saying this is a violent
film and there's violent moments I
wouldn't say it's a violent film overall
yes not it's not quantity it's just that
when violent things happen they are very
intense but they add to the story you
know you know they amplify the
experience II you get like they have
some great makeup effects of the
violence and like it's it's disturb I
remember looking at it going good makeup
effects and I'm like but how do I feel I
feel I feel very uncomfortable like yeah
it's some very like when it's violent
its violent but it acts reasons not to
see some cliche writing in the finale
this is gonna be hard for me to go into
without ruining the film I remember in
the last half-hour getting pulled out
because I was like okay that is some
cliched dialogue yeah you're you're
obviously just saying that to give us
some reveals now cuz this whole time you
got such an authentic written screenplay
out of nowhere what and when it's like
getting close to their cuz I think this
film probably was meant to be like a
two-hour 45 minute movie or three hour
movie but then they have to cut it down
sort of like you know we gotta like
start from it's an expositional dialogue
in here yeah like that there are moments
yeah especially there's a recurring
transition of these slow fade outs as
certain developments are just being made
that I wonder if those were like there
should be a scene here but we have to
move along yeah exactly I felt like
someone sort of told them like you know
what two and a half hours is your limit
yeah exactly
so even in those moments though where
there's some cliche writing there's
still some greatness in some of those
moments as well it's like if there's any
drawback to this film for me there there
are occasions where certain reveals or
certain little explanations for things
didn't quite ring as authentic as the
rest of the movie there's certain
moments where I'm like oh okay it's a
little bit scripty you know that's you
have it a Hollywood thriller but it's
not enough to make me say
the movie by any stretch the balance is
very much skewed toward the writing
being really good it's just there is a
small percentage of like okay we gotta
move stuff long's what decision
Hugh Jackman's son I mean mind the son
but there is this one moment I'm not I'm
gonna ruin it like too much for you but
he's not like the most important
character in the film he blows up at
Hugh Jack he blows up and his dad here
at Lowe's up huge and he blows up Hugh
Jackman and that fight completely
different though yells at Hugh Jackman
and I remember watching that scene and I
actually got very pulled out at that
moment cuz I was like I just don't
believe you man that's just really
seemed like you were acting right there
Oh see I gotta disagree because I feel
almost the same way I was like the son
character is in the movie I'm like he
never has a whole lot to do and then
that one see and I was like oh finally
like you made him actually reroute the
moat yeah I seen that I was like that
yelling Maxine I was like oh [ __ ] like
now you're both into it and that's not
really the actors father's just like
that character doesn't have much to do
other than you know sort of be in the
blank background processing all this but
yeah that one explosion scene I thought
was like when he actually rose to the
occasion you know that was the one that
was the moment that pulled me out the
most out of that whole actors
performance like honestly that actors
performance didn't put me on it until
that one scene - yeah Ryan's Consensus
prisoners is the reason movies are made
prisoners is the reason movies are made
I [ __ ] love this film from acting
writing directing I just did all cast
and crew working together perfectly
fluid as [ __ ] Jerry's Consensus know
what I prisoners is the reason movies
are made prisoners just the recent
movies are made you know at first I
thought I was just gonna give this like
a really strong like a lot of reasons to
see it go see it but thinking about it
now like I want to go back and watch it
again like the acting is great
the mystery is really interesting and
intense just everything for the most
part is top-notch you know - a couple
things so highly recommend it it's the
kind of movie that you want to like take
people to to be like you gotta watch
this film
yes we're because it's
like I said it's not fun is it it's mad
dard but at the same time you're like I
want to go again come on let's go look
see how good this movie alright guys so
check it out a review for prisoners why
don't you go ahead skull that comment
box below and tell us what is your
favorite child abduction movie you sicko
and once you're done trudging the
darkest parts of your psyche come over
here and click this button so you can
see more episodes the reasons to see
once you're done looking into the
darkness of your life once you go ahead
follow us on Twitter right here and like
us on Facebook right here
yeah and then once you're done with all
that stuff perhaps you'd like to get
updated every time a new review or a
video is out so you're gonna wanna
subscribe that's right subscribe click
this box people don't worry we won't do
bad things to you you won't be a
prisoner in the box yeah we won't hold
you prisoner uh-huh let's put a while
since we've both agreed on uh this is
the reason movies are made yeah I know I
am I gonna lie when you said that I was
like a patient we didn't even discuss
this movie before
yeah that was a nice feeling
that was a nice song movies that are
really obvious that are like yeah like
the Avengers we're gonna high-five yeah
but then every once in a while you get a
movie we're like you up I wasn't
expecting to say it but this is one of
the best movies I've seen all year yeah
definitely it's um I might have to put
this we will we can when it comes time
to do another top ten list oh yeah I
have a feeling of unless you know 10
more amazing movies come on this'll be a
disability
yeah no it's it's great Giroud you know
gee have you seen someone do a Hugh
Jackman impression haven't seen someone
do a Hugh Jackman impression I think
we're the first ones